[Music]
head steps for the very first time
pretty recently went shocking right I
know I have Sun bearing hips on a
renaissance body I get it pick your jaws
up off the floor people it was it was
recently people are not lining up to
take this job I was trying so hard I
tried so hard no who wanted it over so
long but yeah lifted the floodgates on
26 years worth of backed up come but it
was a man he drowned
he's dead no no I'm just kidding
I didn't come nice so how long have you
been on tinder okay some more wine sure
I good idea
[Music]
yeah thank you she is so um with it like
in Nepal oh it's fine yeah when uh we
were kids we used to play at the foot of
Mount Everest
really no how are you are you kidding
no you can't do that I didn't I'm not
really familiar with Nepali and
recreations hey Paulie yeah you know you
Americans are so bad bruise this way I
get back there so finish your wine and
send me there
Wow
little music set the mood okay
word word why is for you you're a fluid
body pattern just shut up come on oh you
know Tommy oh shut up it's a shove all I
care but disrespectful thing it's fine
but now that I know little fellows shut
up it's sort of like hard feel that's
not my bedspread just oh oh I think
you're really [ __ ] him you'll see
later
Oh area's not a sax guy huh
okay little what pretty suggestion do
you think we could just like skip all
this and just sort of like get right
into oh look you want it huh sure
damn is naughty okay take those socks
off first though that's gross oh can he
like ten minutes I can [ __ ] you like
that again oh that's okay um you're
probably tired huh let's just call you
an uber okay so did you just call me for
sex
yeah knew it well that's bold yeah thank
you uh your roofers here right okay so
thank you offer me in here one of those
sure last call for booty call I'm am I
gonna see you again oh um I'm gonna take
that as a yes it's it's it no oh okay
yeah yep did it not a virgin anymore not
great
how do you know if you came I walk a lot
uh just around this is a good segue
right guys are you ready to move on I am
who cares about that last joke this has
nothing to do with it um
I walk a lot and I almost got hit by a
car today mm-hmm a Bentley
next time right oh so close
I even slowed down a little you sure you
don't want to go you live the right away
it's not even a crosswalk go come on
I'll just lay down I'll make it easy for
you oh well it didn't work out but I do
I take the train to and the bus and
whatnot it's the only place in LA I feel
pretty on the bus
I am a metro 8 I know you're laughing
cuz you're like I see it
oh I see you too
I see people see it all the time we know
are you okay
don't do it don't do it yep there it is
don't eat we should go over here I can
still see you I like public
transportation I do you learn a lot a
woman leaned over to me the other day
and she said excuse me I really like
your perfume but you don't need men
prefer your natural smell so just to
have your hand on your [ __ ] put in the
back your neck and let the wind do the
work waft it away yeah and then six
gladiators came and carried her away
like the Queen she was it was very nice
very wonderful show of things I wish I
was tough okay just a first and foremost
I wish I was tough every time I watch
Kill Bill I'm like well sure you could
do it why can't I and I used to work at
this really shitty cafe and like my boss
used to go around and say shenanigans
all the time let's try organs and if
you're a grown man who says shenanigans
more than four times a day you touched a
kid
don't make them come on Sinead a special
city and again anyway I wish I was
tougher because I they used to be so
mean to me there you know oh yeah it's
good god mm what kind is this its
chocolate chip mmm thanks I'll think
about it and the one day I was at work
and I was early and this woman came in
hi how are you gonna muffin please sure
okay welcome would you like what kind
you have
well we have plan to blueberry yep that
one games you like it for here to go
what would you like it for here or to go
I was like okay well you didn't say like
I was with the tarp and I'm
double-parked so can you like I said I'm
double-parked can you just hurry it up
well thinking of God do you have it
did you hear me hello so I get the tongs
and I put him on the muffin and I look
at her she's not looking at me she's
looking down and I put the muffin in the
tongs in the back and I thought about
all those times that I've gotten kicked
around you know I just [ __ ] crushed
it it's so good oh but it didn't in
there no no no no I lifted him up drop
the bag until there's nothing left
there's no blueberry left hole scattered
ooh there was dust it was dust revenge
is so sweet and then I took a napkin I
put it on top of the muffin I rolled the
bag back up and then I slid it across
the counter here's your muffin thank you
you know what I wish I'm so sorry it's
just been one of those weeks we're like
you know nothing goes right like my dad
hmm
yeah yeah just died and then like II my
husband I love you want Celine and like
and I'm like oh three kids hey please
take dark you're just gonna go
no no please take this muffin oh please
no God Shh
hi kids I adopted not because I'm barren
but because I've always felt the urge to
help humanity in this way I brought you
guys a muffin to share a billion people
it's not to know what I cannot be let me
see Bob no mommy's dead Oh No hey
there's that day-old Nutella in the back
come on okay just leave anyone here I
could date no nope
Oh coming up empty again who are you
yeah yeah yeah she's right I'm looking
at you okay for my next joke
for my next joke I need to get your
number no it's true it's a it's a it's
part of the joke
go ahead yell it out no one cares smells
gonna dig it down seven six zero zero
five
you know what's funny is that I put you
on the spot
and I made you feel weird saying no
welcome to being a girl I'm not gonna
call you it's no offense or anything I
just took the number down wrong because
I was shaking so sorry you're gonna have
to miss out on all these beautiful drunk
texts I send good ones they're so good
I'll say sorry about everything I told
someone I was fully happy with their
friendship the other day and of drunk
texts who says fully
I'm fully appreciate you mm-hmm
does anyone else ever feel like kind of
killing themselves when someone doesn't
respond to your [ __ ] snapchat
yes it
[Applause]
you
[Music]